wir schauen uns heute gemeinsam die neue
hilf mir folge lebensmittel machen mich
geil an
ja wir uns in das thematische
meisterwerke einstürzen werfen wir mal
kurz einen blick in die kommentare
wie stark soll deine karriere zerstört
sein schauspieler ja ich verspüre die
luft mit einer schere seine haare zu
schneiden luca wo bist du wir brauchen
jemanden der klatscht hilf mir lass wie
queens kannst du sein lasst gerne
augenbrauen von dem mädchen sind dünner
als die erste in meinem garten ich
glaube ohne witz das ist die größte
folge die hilf mir jemals gemacht hat
und ja so nenne ich auch mein heutiges
video und wir starten mit der folge
bedeutungsloses gefehlt wir werden wir
unsere leckeren sachen aufbauen es ist
heute eine veranstaltung vom
kaninchenzuchtverein die feinheit der
jubiläums in ganz ganz wichtige kunden
wie haben ganz ganz viele bangkok mit
[Musik]
gerade die gedanken von dem da
ich glaube dass das glas ist weil wir
hatten jetzt übergeben bei den
kommentaren eine person geschrieben hat
ich verspüre ich lust in die haare zu
schneiden und ich glaube mal dass damit
er gemeint ist hier los alles in ordnung
ja alles gut alles gut ist nun aber so
ein bisschen kaputt aus mein lieber ok
du kapierst hier schön die platten dekor
ist alles schön weil es nur dann dazu
zur ausbildung muss auch gelernt sein
okay ganz kurzer zwischenstand das ist
las und las ist wohl der den
lebensmittel geil machen was man halt
den titel schon daneben konnte und er
soll jetzt bei diesem
kaninchenzuchtverein diese
[Musik]
um neben 2
das scheint eine ausgeprägte libido und
eine ziemlich skurrile vorliebe für
lebensmittel zu haben
der fachbegriff hierfür lautet sie zu
viel wenn er sich so stark von
lebensmitteln angezogen fühlt würde ich
ihm raten den job zu wechseln da es
sonst möglicherweise zu problemen kommen
kann wenn ich will
[Musik]
das sind doch nicht sein
da
mit einer scheidung
menschen schießt ja immer noch so enders
[Musik]
die vorherige aktionär
so stark dass er probleme hat seine
erektion wieder loszuwerden seine
heimliche leidenschaft die er
verständlicherweise vor seinem chef und
seinen kollegen verbirgt sorgt so an
seinem ersten arbeitstag schon für
erhebliche einschränkungen
ich würde am liebsten dieses ding warum
habe ich überhaupt so schlagzeug sticks
bestellt hier veranstalten naja ich habe
doch im leben dem kreislauf gesehen und
ich dachte mit uns ein paar übungen geht
das und ist da rüber zum arbeiten hier
nicht zum sporttreiben ja aber ich kann
dir nachher wieder weiter arbeiten so
bin ich arbeite wie du aussiehst
momentan dann machst du vor feierabend
okay der las macht feierabend aber er
ist doch gerade in seinem lust fahrer
die es damit den ganzen eiern mit
kräutern aus
okay der las wohnen also entscheiden
noch zu hause bei seiner mutter
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie die
reagieren stellen wir das sein leben auf
die reihe christ und um endlich mal eine
liebschaft und solid aus dir wird und
ich verstehe den kommentar immer mehr
von wegen dass man ihm die haare
schneiden will sieht halt ein bisschen
aus wie ein sondern wischmopp ich sag
das ja an jeder hilfe reaktion von mir
und ihr seid doch mittlerweile schon
leid allerdings möchte ich auch heute
wieder sagen denn alle meine kommentare
die ich irgendwie applus es sind weder
beleidigend gemeint noch persönlich
sollen personen attackieren diffamieren
wort aber ich kenne die ganzen leute die
nicht persönlich ich bewerte nur die
schauspieler die rolle und die saas also
diese geschauspielert person ist halt ne
extrem peinliche person wo ich
allerdings raten dabei bin ein bisschen
was zu erzählen er wollte ich noch ganz
gut sagen dass dieses nicht t shirt also
das gibt auch zukauf von lukas stocker
über das hier das ist ja der podcast von
sandra und mehr dick und doof da ja
gerade nur zu hause herumsitzt haben wir
uns gesagt dass wir ab jetzt täglich
podcast folgen rausbringen also die
donnerstags folgen die 45 minuten langes
bleibt bestehen und an jedem anderen tag
kommt eine kurze 15 bis 20 minuten live
update folge von sandra aus bielefeld
und mir aus köln wir telefonieren und
nehmen das zusammen auf und jetzt gerade
ging sogar schon die erste folge online
also schaut mal in der beschreibung
vorbei folgt uns bei spotify war und
jetzt schauen wir uns weiter die folge
anlass sein zu hause bei seiner mutter
nicht viel zu melden
war
die therapie
und hier steht er und streichelten
ciabatta baguette oder was wenn ich hier
sieht ich müsste eigentlich zu hause
sein im bett liegen ich gehe diesen
ärger mit der musik der
krankheitsbedingt arbeitsunfähig ist ist
nicht bewegungsunfähig ist ein
allgemeiner rechtsirrtum zu glauben dass
man das haus nicht verlassen darf nur
weil man
[Musik]
mr
mein gott okay das ist das erste mal
dass mir so eine hilf mir personal was
wirklich was beigebracht hat
ich bin mal gespannt wo sie hingehen das
wäre krass wenn jetzt in irgendeine
lebensmittels kaffee ich habe schon
gedacht dass die gehen jetzt auf
irgendein wochenmarkt oder sohn der
kommt gar nicht klar eiscafé wird glaube
ich jetzt auch kritisch das ist woanders
hingehen
wer sagt denn dass wir wegen 1 hier sind
ich habe so eine überraschung für dich
ja ich verstehe und mein gott
sie will für ihn eine freundin suchen
[Musik]
okay das ist die mit den mit den
augenbrauen diese dünnen sind wie die
erste bei dem einen kommentar schreiben
im garten
das ist oberpeinlich
[Musik]
das
also
mal deine augen bauen auf wie du
möchtest
dass das sieht schon ein bisschen aus
wie wenn man ein böses gesicht malen
sollte sondern böses mai die damals ja
auch einfach nur so zwei augen und zwei
striche passiert ist sie fließt sie ist
smileys und böser smiley ist sie wieder
überhaupt nicht böse gemeint wenn man es
mag dann ist das das ist ja komplett
ok ich stimme in meinem titel und dem
kommentar der kleinen eisfläche stadt
auch okay jetzt nimmt er das auch ein
eisbecher und ich glaube jetzt wird es
ein bisschen kritisch weil als ja wegen
lebensmitteln gibt es auch so siehst
dass du mit geschrieben hast die jungs
machen würdest du prima deine augen
leuchten die sterne und auch aus der
ferne
oh mein gott was soll man sich im
internet für ihren sohn ausgibt ist zwar
moralisch bedenklich in rechtlicher
hinsicht bleibt es aber folgenlos
es handelt sich um eine lüge durch die
niemand zu schaden gekommen ist alles
klar
die modi ich will doch nur dass der last
mit der ca ein bisschen es da auch
sammelt im garten
[Musik]
ich brauche so ein potsdamer
was euch die szene hier gerade komplett
zensieren weil er da sein bauch einreibt
mit mit eisdicke schön jetzt ist er
wieder zurück bei der arbeit pvda zu
einer viertel tonne
dieser macht ja komisch und melone
honigmelone was machst du da
[Musik]
irgendwie finde ich die folge nicht mehr
nur krimi sondern irgendwie auch so ein
bisschen gruselig verstörend wirken
slater vorbei
es gibt doch nicht sss gibt es gibt
einen zweiten teil
[Musik]